have you ever been offered a role that
went on to become a banger and you were
like
well one role i was offered and i don't
feel bad about it because the right guy
did it uh and i couldn't have done it at
the time at that time i couldn't have
done it i got all for tony soprano uh in
the sopranos whoa
and i don't feel no i don't in fact i i
mean this sincerely i don't feel bad
about it at all
because james
who i knew was so brilliant yeah and so
wonderful and such a good person and i
couldn't have done it at that time i
couldn't have done it
you know so
i i just couldn't do it at the time but
i i read it and i did love the pilot but
i just couldn't do it so i
i couldn't do it so maybe i shouldn't
say i i turned it down i did get offered
it and the second one that i it still
bugs me
till this day it bugs me because i love
the movie so much and that was donnie
brasco and that was the role of uh sonny
black
sonny
black story or joker stone
michael madden
was great he killed that thing he killed
it but i i was offended first at the
time yeah uh but he killed it and i was
directing something at the time and i
but i could have worked it out if i just
would have did it i went ah no i don't
want to do it and it's one of my
favorite movies of all time
one of my favorite movies and i think
it's one of owl's greatest performances
yeah yeah johnny depp i and i'm so upset
that i turned it down because i love the
movie so much it's such a brilliant
movie you i think you would have been
monstrous in that role so when you see
these roles that these guys absolutely
kill michael matson and then james
gandolfini do you feel happy for them is
that like okay my career has been great
man of course yeah
i mean he i mean iconic in that role as
well sometimes it just works out you
know sometimes the right person ends up
doing it and they were the right people
so that's fine you know be grateful man
you know life has been good for me life
is a matter with you
seriously just smack me in the head
right now
you got to be i'm great i'm so grateful
you know i'm playing with house money
man i mean come on so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you